ALICIA WILLIAMS: Hi, I'm Alicia.
And today, I'll
be talking to you
about how to apply best
practices of REST APIs
to GraphQL.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GraphQL is an open source
data query and manipulation
language for APIs and a
runtime for fulfilling queries
with existing data.
It's a new way to
think about APIs.
With GraphQL, you
can send queries
to get exactly the data you're
looking for in one request.
GraphQL can enable
front and backend teams
to collaborate more smoothly
when developing applications.
Let's look at an example
of a GraphQL query.
Here, we are querying for user
data with the ID of the user.
The first thing to note about
the query and the response
is that they are identical.
This is because
GraphQL is typed,
meaning that what you ask
for is what you get back.
We are simply just saying,
get me the user with this ID
and return me back their
name, posts, and followers.
Now let's compare this to how
we would get the same results
using a REST endpoint.
Here, we have had to define
three separate endpoints
in order to have the ability
to access the same data.
Some of you might
say that you could
reduce this down to
just one endpoint
by returning the entire user
object in the first request.
This would be seen as
overfetching of data.
One key difference to note
here is that with GraphQL, you
know which objects
and data you have
available with each
query, so you can specify
the shape of the data you would
like back from the server.
With REST, you
can't really define
what is returned to you,
as the server decides this.
So we can think of GraphQL
as a single endpoint
upon which we have a set
of executable queries
that map to a
schema of the data.
There are three key benefits
of using this approach.
First of all, all
data exchange is
performed at a single endpoint.
That means granularity
for data load,
execution of requests in
parallel, and query planning.
It also means if one resolver
fails, the rest of the query
can still resolve and
return useful data.
Secondly, the real strength
is in the query language.
You can declare which schemas
you want the data from
and the format of that data,
which prevents overfetching
and underfetching of data.
And thirdly, availability
of native integration
with the ReactJS UI framework
and other client libraries
considerably increases
productivity for developers.
GraphQL is great, but how
does it compare to REST?
There are a number of
differences between the two,
and I'll highlight
four of these.
When we compare
the endpoints, REST
makes many smaller
requests to many endpoints
and the URL taxonomy is used as
a logical API resource manager.
GraphQL, on the other
hand, makes requests
to one endpoint, which results
in longer and larger queries
for customer data.
REST uses HTTP verbs and
generally uses JSON XML
in order to exchange that data.
GraphQL uses POST
most of the time
and also leverages
different query types
specified inside the
protocol, not in HTTP.
Even though GraphQL
uses a custom query
language on the request,
JSON is returned as a result.
When we compare
documentation, we'll
see that REST uses open
API specifications,
while GraphQL uses a
schema-generated documentation.
Frequently, we see customers
using GraphiQL or GraphQL
Playground to interact with
schema-based GraphQL endpoints.
From a discovery
perspective, the portal
offers a veritable
playground for developers
to try out APIs before they
use them in their code,
while GraphQL comes with
a built-in playground that
enables users to explore new
queries on the fly, including
automatic tab completion.
While the two solutions
are very different,
there are a number of best
practices in REST APIs that
can be applied to GraphQL.
Let's quickly look at
these best practices.
Consistency in GraphQL starts
with well-formed GraphQL.
And we can apply the best
practices of well-formed REST
here.
Here's an example.
You would never expect
a well-formed REST query
to be a list of
employees by department.
Rather, a well-formed REST
query would be a resource.
A graph hierarchy
is fundamentally
a data-driven hierarchy.
It is not a
functional hierarchy,
like an object model.
We should be treating
GraphQL like Java functions.
In other words, be
data-oriented, not
function-oriented.
The second best
practice is around
submitting and retrieving data.
Those are not always
mirrored operations.
In REST, we frequently
submit and receive data
from different URLs.
In particular, when
retrieving data
from multiple services in a
microservice architecture,
Command Query
Responsibility Segregation--
CQRS-- is common.
As we think about how
this applies to GraphQL,
we need to consider that query
mutations can get very complex
very quickly, especially with
many different types when
submitting very little data.
Applying CQRS to GraphQL can
help us avoid this challenge.
The third is optimizing
for reusability.
In REST, we think a lot
about our URL taxonomy,
pagination, and filtering,
because developers can then
predict what the behavior
will be of any API they call.
In GraphQL, we should
be doing the same thing.
With GraphQL, it is important
to be careful with schema
stitching, because
to the developer,
the representation looks
like one big graph.
But the behavior of the JSON
returned might be different.
So relay cursor
connections and input hints
should all present
uniform behavior,
regardless of the portion of
the graph being requested.
Even with the best
practices I mentioned,
there are a number of challenges
with GraphQL deployments.
These revolve around
authentication
and authorization.
For example, GraphQL
doesn't solve authorization
and does not support
authorization
for schema browsing.
GraphQL doesn't
support a standard
for throttling or quotas.
It does not have a
unified view of analytics,
which means expanding the view
of APIs from simple metrics
to business and
operational impact metrics
can be challenging.
And it is based on a
single endpoint, which
means that there are no
URL versions and no support
for header or format versioning.
An API management
solution can help
with managing the
challenges of GraphQL APIs.
An API management
platform gives you
control over and visibility
into the APIs that connect
application and data
cross-cloud or on-premises.
Managing your GraphQL APIs
with an API management platform
enables you to easily
manage authentication
and authorization, implement
throttling or quotas,
view detailed analytics,
and streamline versioning.
To learn more and get
started, check out the links
in the description below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]